[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and we have a brand
new look at the upcoming Breaking Bad
movie El Camino after the Emmy Awards
last night the trailer that was released
online
unfortunately confirmed some about worst
fears and that is that Walter White
played by Bryan Cranston is in fact dead
after perishing in the last episode of
season 5 titled Felina I'm going to play
the trailer in a bit in case you haven't
seen it but there's a key detail that
you need to listen out for which is the
amount of victims that were left in the
wake of Walt's final play this
highlights just how many people died
during the massacre and unfortunately it
looks like Walt was among them here's
the trailer
[Music]
rific scene with multiple victims
it started when neighbors reported
hearing hundreds of gunshots fired when
albuquerque police arrived they
discovered the bodies of nine male
victims many shot multiple times veteran
police officers calling the level of
carnage quote staggering apparently or
remote controlled machine gun was used
in the killings investigators are
searching for a person of interest who
fled the scene and he
with information on this massacre is
asked to call police immediately
[Music]
okay so the main bit of evidence that
confirms that Walt is indeed dead comes
with the line on the radio report that
says the bodies of nine male victims if
you're a youtuber with too much time on
your hands then chances are that you
went back and counted but on the off
chance that you not don't worry because
I did it just for you unfortunately
Jack's gang did only have eight members
so it's a pretty safe assumption to make
that the ninth body was in fact what
white now I've seen some people say that
if this was the case then why didn't the
media report the infamous Heisenberg
being amongst the dead but for whatever
reason they just didn't Jack's gang was
made up of Jack Kenny
Matt Frankie Lester two unnamed
characters and Todd which makes eight
and unfortunately that means that the
ninth body was Walter now could the
authorities be hiding the death of Walt
in order to interrogate him to
potentially find the whereabouts of
Jesse unbeknownst to the character
possibly however I do believe that Walt
is indeed dead even though Bryan
Cranston has confirmed that he will be
returning to the show this will likely
be in flashback or even as a
hallucination for Jesse and I'd love to
see a similar aesthetic to the Joker and
Batman in the Arkham Knight game in
which the character is very much in
Jesse's mind but still guiding him in
one form or another
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the entire thing and if you
still believe that somehow someway
Walter is alive I do think it cheapens
the finale if he is but who knows that
was meant to be the wrap-up of the
entire Breaking Bad saga and they
brought it back for this so yeah there
is potential comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it make sure you check out
my breakdown of the new story that
Joaquin Phoenix stormed out of an
interview with The Telegraph which will
be linked at the end I give my thoughts
on the entire story as well as how the
media twists things to fit its own
agenda so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books and you can pull
them in Twitter a definition whitey it's
the best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there
after this also just wanna let you know
that we're giving away a free copy of
spider-man Barbara
and blu-ray and all you have to do to be
in with a chance of winning is to like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on if Walt is alive or dead in the
comments section below the winner will
be chosen at random October the 15th and
the blue arrow be shipped out from the
until we get surprised it's the best of
luck to everyone he takes part this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]